mr. president welcome to the program you
are here on your first ung a president
Trump is also making his first address
to the to the world you have many areas
of disagreement with the current
president amongst them the Iran nuclear
deal where you think that you should
stay in it
president Trump has told the UN in his
first global speech that this is the
worst deal that he's ever seen in
history and that one way or another they
the deal is an embarrassment to the
United States and I don't think you've
heard the last of it believe me in a
sign that he's preparing to weaken the
deal what do you take from that do you
think he's gonna pull out you've spoken
to him about it
I helped know and I think it would be a
big mistake
I think if Prison III I don't say that
this Iran deal it's a nuclear deal with
Iran is the Alpha and Omega of
everything about how to deal with Iran
if present rams considers it's not
sufficient I do agree with that we have
this deal I think that the outcome of
this deal is that now we have a
monitoring process with the
international agency following the
situation and I think that it's it's
better than nothing okay why because if
we stop with this dough if we just stop
with the nuclear agreement so we will
enter into a situation very similar to
the Korean sea to North Korean situation
before what happens this summer so I
think it would be a big mistake now this
deal has to be completed and probably I
will try to convince President Frank
that's the best way to address its
concerns regarding Iran is to work into
that direction first we have to work in
order to have a monitoring process on
ballistic missiles and ballistic
activity of Iran that's a concern is
that a concern for the whole region we
have to work on it and we need a new
agreement and we can we can work on
sanctions and agreements on this
ballistic side and second we have to
complete the 2015 new
their agreement with Iran for the period
past 2025 because this agreement just
cover still 2025 the situation but on
the balance it makes the world a safer
place to have this nuclear deal
definitely you know you have today some
governments not compliant with
international rules and trying to get
nuclear weapons that's it that's the
situation we have with North Korea and
there's a situation we have with some
other countries okay the more you you
contain the situation the more you
monitor is the more you put
international agents and you follow the
situation very carefully the more you
can intervene and contain their
influence I want to follow this line and
I think if we just stop with the deal
because it was a deal negotiated by mr.
president Obama I mean it's not a good
reason to stop with the 2015 deal and
what about President Trump at this
moment of maximum global crisis over
North Korea calling him at the UN
Rocketman talking about destroying you
know the capabilities but very very
provocative language look I think what
we have to do and what we we need is to
be efficient I think that North Korean
president is probably not very sensitive
to what happened to the UN he's not a
great client of the city and the United
Nations the guys in his own world my
point is not to increase pressure and
words against words what we have to do
is to find the appropriate answer to
decrease tension and protect people
people in the region and I want to think
of South Korean people living in big
anxiety I want to think about so all
region and our Japanese friends friends
and I will see a Japanese Prime Minister
during this trip in New York and I think
the Hutt's the whole word because we I
mean we speak about a global threat
today so for me it's how to decrease the
tension has to contain
the North Korean situation and how to
increase the pressure to dis is Khalid
do you think there's a military solution
I mean sometimes the president seems to
indicate that there's a military
solution to North Korea look at the map
if you think there is a military
solution you speak about a lot of
victims I do believe in multilateralism
because I do believe in negotiation I do
believe in how to control I do believe
in building peace and I think that's
what we exactly what we have to do in
this region the president told the
United Nations in his speech that he
wants a tougher better deal he's very
concerned also about North Korea I spoke
to the Iranian president who says the US
will pay if they pull out of this deal
what is your view on that and what have
you said to mr. Trump I know you
discussed it last night sure and I
discussed successively with President
Trump and president rouhani about this
issue first of all our main anxiety
today regarding nuclear weapon is about
North Korea and this situation is to be
handled very carefully we have to avoid
military answer we have to increase
pressure on North Korea especially
coming from China and Russia because
North Korea is very dependent from these
two countries and we have to decrease
the pressure and stabilize the situation
but North Korea is a very good
illustration of a what-if scenario from
nuclear deal with Iran why because we
stopped everything with North Korea
years and years ago we stopped any
monitoring any discussions with them and
what's the result they will probably get
nuclear weapon so my position for ayrenn
deserve a president ramp was to say look
at the situation on North Korea I don't
want to replicate the security situation
with Iran let me ask you about how you
deal with President Trump because he
says some things in person he says some
things on Twitter his ministers say
other things how do you deal with the
leader of the free world in this kind of
situation some have described it as kind
of chaotic some say they don't quite
know who to listen to
what
does president Macomb use to deal with
the President of the United States
I have very direct discussions with
President Trump I do appreciate him we
have a very good personal relationship
and and I have very direct discussion
with them
I don't interfere in in domestic poses
and what you describe as interferences
or discrepancies between different
members for me there is one voice your
presence you elected your present and
and this is the voice I consider and the
man icepick with and and it's always the
same thing we we share our views he's
very direct and I think I think listen
to what I propose what are the main
areas of disagreement right now I think
the very first these disagreements is
very well known is about climate and as
president Trump decided to leave Paris
agreement I mean that's his choice and I
do respect his choice and he was elected
on the basis of such a decision but I do
regret this decision and and I do want
to convince him to come back to this
agreement because for me that's the core
agreements for climate and I I do
believe that especially after the serie
Kings
we just had both in the US and in France
we do see the direct consequences of co2
emissions and and all this climate
change we have to fight against this
climate change and we need the global
mobilization for that so we have a
disagreement on this issue but I will
keep pushing we have direct discussion
yesterday we will implement Paris
agreement on our own at the French level
but the European level as well we have a
strong agreement with the Chinese and
the older pours and I think it's very
important to preserve this multilateral
approach and now is that an issue for
the u.s. itself to see what they want to
do and what President Trump wants to do
with his climate but we have to deal
with that the president says this is a
bad deal we can get a better deal it's
bad for the economy it's bad for the
climate it's bad for the United States
what do you say when he says that to you
I mean first of all it's not bad for the
climate for climate and environment
definitely and especially if he decides
to leave it will be worse because the
u.s. is a very great contributor in
terms of co2 emission so that's an issue
and if you don't fix the situation in
the US you aren't credible to tell the
others what they have to do and you have
direct consequences of the situation so
no this agreement is not bad for climate
it's wrong on them on them even the
short mid and long run is that a good
agreement for the US and for all of us
why because it's true that in order to
deal with climate change you will have
to change a lot of things in our
economies I mean you will have to stop
certain activities regarding fossil
fuels regarding classical industrial
activities because we know that they
pollute a lot but you will create new
jobs to reduce emissions it means more
innovation more jobs in cleaner sectors
which brings me then to the very major
philosophical point that you're making
which is continue the historical
relationship continue multilateralism be
really part of the world you know
president Trump has said make America
great again
he sort of kind of shifts between being
part of the world and being you know
protectionist and isolationist
what gave you the courage to go against
that trend during your election campaign
I remember before the election you said
this is a great moment for France to go
in the opposite direction of the
prevailing trends you know take on
anti-globalization take on populism what
made you do that and believed that you
could win doing that because I know the
outcome of this trend it's wrong I do
know the outcome of this turn a tional
ism is all about war we experienced that
80 years ago in Europe so at the end of
the day if if you believe that there is
nothing to change this trend and we have
to accept anti-globalization anti
materialism problem nationalism what
action ISM and so on it's all about at
the end of the day it's all about how to
fight against each other and it's all
about war
you